what was interesting was when trump was
in power and he started this whole thing
everyone thought well he's an evil man
he's a
horrible individual and he he started
this and he doesn't care
and everyone has so much hope that when
biden comes in he's going to reverse
this decision he will put conditions on
this peace process
he will do something or he will just
extend the withdrawal date to make sure
there's a meaningful discussion and
actually he made it a thousand times
worse
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people a brilliant and important guest
we have for you today she is the founder
of conservative friends of afghanistan
shaban nasimi welcome to trigonometry
thank you for having me it's so great to
have you on the show uh thanks for
coming on it's obviously a very
difficult time at the moment as we speak
before we get into the issue of
afghanistan itself talk to us a little
bit about who you are what is your story
what is your journey through life how do
you find yourself sitting here talking
to us
thank you um well originally my family
came to the uk in 1999 which was just
two years prior to the 911 attacks
and they had studied in the former
soviet union um
then directly affiliating themselves
with russia and
its system
[Laughter]
and as a result of that um they knew
that um they were directly targeted by
the taliban its regime
who
do not agree with anyone who have
western
values or i guess seen as would soviet
union people thought that you were an
atheist um who didn't believe in islam
and
you know that's how you're targeted and
that's the same case today as well
but
um you know we grew up in in london and
southeast
and
i have two
younger sisters and one brother um
and i think with most minority ethnic
groups
from a young age when you know you've
come from a country that has very little
opportunity
um you work a lot harder a lot
harder to to get to a point where you're
recognized and you're heard and i think
particularly for afghans it's even more
so
um because we come from one of the most
war-torn countries in the world uh one
of the most impoverished
that um
in comparison to even our neighbors of
pakistan iran and
india and central asia
afghans tend to struggle a lot more
in terms of integration and getting
adjusted in the societies they end up
resettling in
so
yeah it's not been an easy journey um
i'm proud of where i am today but
i will get on to that in a bit um
but that's sort of my very my story in a
very nutshell and your family escaped
afghanistan
and came here as refugees via a bunch of
countries didn't they they did it was
the
normal route the refugees normally take
you sort of give up your your life your
home your belongings your family and you
trek through pakistan or either iran and
move across to
uh to europe first getting into arriving
at greece italy france dover and then
the uk and we actually came in a
container at the time so it was a
container that um
uh was carried in one of those ferries
that comes to the uk from calais um
and it was sort of pitch black um the
only thing the only thing i can remember
from that point is uh it was very
difficult to breathe and my my dad
wanted to make sure that we were calm
um so he had matchsticks and kept
lighting them up so that we could he
could we could see a little bit um and
it was only me and my sister at the time
my younger brother and sister were born
here but um yeah no it's not it's not a
journey you take out of choice that's
that's um that's definitely the case and
it's something that a lot of people feel
that you've given up your dignity and
your respect to come in that way to
another country and i think it's
probably
with the current situation in
afghanistan
um it's really important to stress that
what's happening and the fact that a lot
of countries are now offering
resettlement um that it's not out of
choice no one really wants to leave
your home your comfort to go somewhere
else and in such difficult situations
well look we'll talk about the refugee
issue probably later on but let's let's
just go back for people watching this
they've seen afghanistan in the news
let's be honest most people in the west
have absolutely couldn't find
afghanistan on a map right so just take
us back through the last 20 years
particularly so your family left in 99
soon after that uh al qaeda uh attack
the the twin towers in new york uh
destroy them kill thousands of people in
america
america
retaliates you could say or goes into
afghanistan to deal with the problem of
the terrorists that were being allowed
to set up bases there to train etc
talk us through that and everything
that's happened since so that we have a
good grounding for the conversation that
we have sure so um
on the year of 2001 um the northern
alliance in afghanistan which was led by
the former ahmed shah masood and doston
one is from the target ethnic group and
the other from the uzbek ethnic group
both actually began fighting against the
taliban um quite was you know formed a
strong resistance in a movement um
then as a result the taliban collapsed
in their regime and that's when the u.s
stepped in and provided that aircraft
the logistics the power the the forces
to help afghans completely remove the
taliban announced them
from afghanistan and the mission was a
was primarily targeted targeted at um
destroying the al-qaeda and its networks
and the taliban as well um which was
partially successful uh of course you
can't really get rid of an extremist
group completely they're you know
leaving even a seat of them um doesn't
mean that you know they will continue to
flourish and with the taliban they're
trained particularly on the other side
of the border of pakistan
uh in madrasas really extreme islamic
schools from a very young age so
um it's why they've been able to return
today but going back to what happened in
2001
once that nato and the international
community came and went in the whole
world's attention was in afghanistan
trillions in aid was spent
um
money interest effort sacrifices i mean
2 000 american forces died and 450
british soldiers died so people made
heavy sacrifices in afghanistan an
effort
and a lot of time
because they wanted to not only remove
the extremism in the terrorist groups
but also
nation build
and so the mission wasn't focused on
just
uh destroying extremism but also
creating society and a system so
when they went into afghanistan they had
to start from scratch there was
practically no infrastructure no health
health system no education no schools
the roads had to be fixed
everything it was a blank canvas
so
what the reason why this
last few days have been so difficult um
is because if you had just gone in there
to remove the taliban and you were only
fighting with them
it would have been a different story but
you went in there to develop
a country you developed a nation
that
had hope that were fighting for
something and in the last 20 years
afghanistan progressed incredibly it
wasn't perfect i don't think any country
anywhere in the world would say that in
20 years they became a developed country
and changed
europe wasn't made in 20 years neither
was the us or anywhere else but 20 years
in afghanistan because so much attention
was put into into the country all at
once
schools were built there was almost 40
50
of the students in universities and
schools were girls
and there were female journalists
um there were actresses there was
musicians singers that were performing
with without scarves which is uh which
was quite strongly in one of my iranian
friends that saw videos of female um um
singers in afghanistan performing they
said we can't do that in iran without a
scarf how come you guys can women can
perform and sit amongst men without
without
a head cover
um so it was astonishing for iranians
and it was also astonishing for a lot of
central asian and pakistani countries as
pakistan as well sort of south asian
countries because they said that you had
such a free press
you were able to criticize the president
you were able to criticize the
government and officials without any um
consequences whereas most of these
countries
it's not saying even you know russia
today is still um
you can't really speak against putin a
nice little dick at my people yeah
you can just don't drink the tea yeah
exactly um but afghanistan yeah and that
was the case you know
i i traveled to afghanistan a few times
over the last 20 years every year or
every other year visited family visited
friends
and there were points where i went out
and walked outside without any family
members in the beginning i was a bit
terrified i thought maybe my uncle or my
aunt or my cousin had to go with me
because i didn't know i wasn't
unfamiliar
but
slowly eventually i could i could just
walk around anywhere on my own
so that was the progress uh women were
outside in cafe shops and restaurants
sitting like we are today
comfortably um
and that's been taken away so that's
the last 20 years what was created was
a nation that was moving forward and one
more importantly
75
of afghanistan is under the age of 25
approximately
the majority of the new generation today
never lived under a taliban rule
all they knew was the last 20 years
so this was a new generation like a
complete new chapter
starting fresh
who have only seen progress and moving
up
um
so
the mentality changed the psyche changed
people lived in under western liberal
liberalized democrat democratic values
and i think what one thing that people
fail to understand is that it wasn't
forced upon them you know a lot of
stopped the coalition or stopped the war
sort of war coalition groups and people
who are against the intervention say you
know we can't go there and impose our
system on others it doesn't work
in countries like afghanistan yes you've
got to understand that this is a tribal
country there's lots of different sects
lots of different groups
you've got to embrace culture and the
people but you went there and you
introduced democracy and people wanted
it they didn't kick you out they didn't
force you out they didn't fight with you
they embraced it really strongly they
loved living in a free society so it
wasn't imposed um they accepted it so
to sort of to some to summarize
a lot was done a lot had changed a lot
of sacrifice was made um and so this is
why the last few days and the
consequences of the withdrawal has been
so hard to accept and before we get into
that the question i really wanted to ask
is who are the taliban because people
often we talk about them but no one
really explains who they are where
they're from their belief system
why is it that they want to
you know overthrow you know the current
government and how were they empowered
before
the taliban are an extreme islamist
group
um
they are tribal
in their mentality so
there is an honor code that they go
through sort of their practice so in
terms of ethnicity
majority of them are from the pashtun
ethnic group of afghanistan today
they're a little bit more diverse
they're recruiting from all
sects but originally from that that
ethnic group and
they live
in
in sort of societies that are
very patriarchal men are allowed outside
girls aren't
um girls do not have or women do not
have the right to study to
work
um their responsibility is basically to
look after their family members and
their husband and to produce children um
and
their system and what they want for
afghanistan
is basically a very very fundamental
form of islam that allows no freedom um
in some ways i feel they they're trying
to act like god and they think
they are god you know punishing a woman
who steps outside without the right
clothes and
if um she is heard to have had any
relations with a man any type even a
conversation without justification
without a proper sort of legal
um court proceeding in terms of finding
out whether adultery for instance
actually happened or anything like that
they would stone a woman um
and
i mean i in terms of the religious
aspect of it i don't think i can go into
too detail to sort of understand
what um script they're using and the
different types of islamic practices but
what i do know is that
there
there isn't uh
with with the with the taliban it's very
similar to al-qaeda and isis but the
only difference is that they're very
tribal in their mentality
and they're a group that
in afghanistan
have come
primarily from pakistan
and are also uh trained in madrasas from
a very young age um
very young so
teenagers and so they're so brainwashed
that when by the time they you know
grow up to about 20 30 years old they
know nothing other than violence and
brutality and and and killing so
it's basically an actual fundamental
extremist islamic group so what you have
is
modern society well very modern for
what we know from afghanistan and then
we have the taliban how is it that the
taliban with less resources without the
american dollars without american
technology have managed to overthrow the
afghan
army backed by the u.s the uk et cetera
et cetera
well this is the question that's been
asked a few times this past week even
biden actually said why are we going to
fight when the afghan forces aren't
fighting um first of all nato actually
haven't been fighting since 2014 they've
been their non-combat role they've
simply been there to provide morale
support logistics and training
unfortunately though afghanistan has
have had um
a very corrupt government
um
in that
the support that the government should
have been given the armed forces wasn't
available so a lot of soldiers from what
i was hearing
were not receiving their salaries they
weren't being funded properly they
weren't being supported by the
government as either so they were quite
isolated and left alone and then in the
last year or so when nato and the us
announced they were leaving the taliban
were on their own fighting with neither
the government support nor nato's
i mean the a lot of people question and
say well if we haven't been able to
create a strong army in the last 20
years
where did all that money go the first
couple of years i guess the first 10
years was when you the intense training
was what was happening
in the latter half of this two decades
they were given the logistics and the
support again
i don't think there are there's any
military in the world that would have
been able to do what they have done in
the last 20 years
so you can't just take away the
logistics the aircraft the equipment and
say
okay here you go get on with it
and that's practically what was done you
took everything from them and you let
them fight on their own with very little
equipment
no weapons hold on i'm sorry to
interrupt what about the taliban it's
not like they have
you know american warplanes and drones
and and
com sophisticated equipment i think
they're funded very well though they're
funded really well um the the
most of the force uh the
soldiers in the afghan army are coming
come from very impoverished homes
they're very poor um a lot of my own
father's family are
are serving in the army and from what i
hear it was either become a soldier or
die from hunger because there was no
other choice to join was to simply be
able to make an income
so
they weren't all very skilled um
it wasn't a choice motivated or
motivated it was simply to to make a
living
um and i think
in this last couple of months
um
there's a lot of political um issues
with this as well in that province after
province was just given to the taliban
quite easily people weren't fighting
there wasn't resistance
a lot of soldiers knew that if they
fought and
and there was a lot of sentiment that
the taliban gonna win there was a lot
more you saw in the media i think also
that worsened the situation in that when
you're saying that they're gonna win
you're already changing people's
mindsets so
they're not gonna have the confidence to
continue fighting um
so it was actually a conversation that i
had with the foreign office recently
where we were working on seeing if we
can do a counter taliban propaganda
campaign because by talking about the
taliban winning you're already
instilling that narrative on people's
minds and people will just run away
rather than fight i think it's the same
with the soldiers as well
they just believe that it's going to
happen why fight and die um if no one
really cares and no one's going to help
us
and
today any soldier that
is captured by the taliban is
killed in a really really brutal way and
they've already been cases uh that i've
seen videos that i've seen
um so i'm sure many of those soldiers
knew that
because we we were fighting directly
against the taliban and we were fighting
for a foreign-backed uh army um that we
will be killed so a lot of them just ran
away and i i think details are important
when you say killed in a really brutal
way what are we actually talking about
here well actually i saw a video today
of a
army general being caught his hand tied
blindfolded
on his knees and shot about 100 times
in kandahar
so it's it's it's just very difficult to
even imagine it's
to even speak about um
another friend of mine who served in
afghanistan two tours
um
[Music]
posted on social media that's 12 men
that he had been working with
um have been executed in in la shergar
in kandahar as well
so that's already started and the
brutality and the way they kill
other family members that i know and
friends
the soldiers have had to go into hiding
but the taliban are going dorsal
patrolling and doing house searches so
they'll go into the house
they'll look around they'll see who's at
home
they'll um take the cars
um
and any property
and there was actually one house that
were going to take the house as well um
but they found a way to negotiate excuse
me um and and allow them to the family
members to stay
but if that
um soldier was captured um and they're
clearly looking for him um
he would face the same type of
savage brutality and murder
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website well if you do then easy
dns are the company for you easy dns is
the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be council culture d
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows a bit about
that so will you in a second easy dns of
rock rock-solid network infrastructure
and incredible customer support they're
in your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you'd know about that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now all you've got to do
is head over to easydns.com
forward slash triggered and use our
promo code which is of course triggered
as well and you will get 50 percent off
the initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy that tells you
everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
that being the case how can you possibly
have
a
modern country when you have these types
of religious extremists i mean what
would you do with these people is ca can
you rehabilitate them do you simply have
to wipe them off the surface of the
earth or are you constantly going to be
in this quasi-civil war with them
well it's a difficult one because
a lot of people argue that we the west
made the mistake of not including the
taliban in
peace talks right from the beginning
um and seeing whether they would be
willing
to be part of afghan society have a part
in this government
um
and
start to
uh be assimilated integrate into the
police and the army
um and work alongside um others
i don't know whether that would have
been the case because clearly they have
no interest in working or compromising
at all um
in the last few days they said we want
unconditional power initially
the agreement was there'll be a
transitional government for six months
where someone will just step in until an
agreement is made in terms of it will be
a 50 50 arrangement
who's whose responsibility will be you
know what but they said we're not going
we're not coming back without a hundred
percent um
and that's it and we wanted the emirates
um islamic camera of afghanistan nothing
less than that so
it's a difficult question to answer i
think
probably a lot of people thinking that
with a group like that existing
[Music]
if we stay 20 30 40 50 years if they're
still going to come back
and retrain and regroup what's the point
but i think
if we had stayed
for longer like we have in you know in
the us are still in south korea you know
we stayed for a very long time in
germany we're in cyprus and you've got
hong kong you know we've got army and um
soldiers all around
but by persisting and enduring you
develop a society that eventually can
can fight on its own i think 20 years
was too early had you given it 40 years
or probably a little bit more than that
potentially you would have created a
society that was resilient and would
have been able to stand on its own two
feet and fight independently but you
pulled everything way too quickly uh
expecting them to just deal with it on
their own well the the counter argument
and a lot of people have made including
uh uh
we've recorded the interview but he will
be our former guest because we had we
recorded him before ricky baxton from
the henry jackson society and he's
written a piece in this in spiked
talking about the fact that actually
many of the things that you've put and
of course you're entitled to put them to
us about the progress has been made in
afghanistan in the last 20 years is
western wistful thinking more than
reality for example he quotes polls from
only a few years ago which showed that
99 percent of muslims in afghanistan
want sharia law
94 percent think that wives should
always obey their husbands 85 percent
think the penalty for adultery should be
stoning and on and on we go so if we've
been in afghanistan that long
and
with all of the things you've talked
about girls going to school in
university being free from wearing
headscarf whatever really have we made
that much progress there has society
moved on
particularly and maybe it's also there's
two questions in what i'm saying that's
the first part have we made enough
progress and the second part is
is it maybe just the weakness of western
liberal democratic thinking that
if you are
an islamic islamist fundamentalist and
you believe that if you sacrifice
yourself on the battlefield you're going
to go to heaven
where you're going to be surrounded by
virgins and you're fighting against
someone who's fighting for human rights
and freedom
it's not quite as strong and motivating
force to to fight and to die and to
sacrifice your life or something do you
see what i'm saying yeah so those two
questions talk to us about that the
first i would say if that was the case
and we actually haven't made much of a
difference you wouldn't be seeing people
fleeing today
if they wanted to live under such a
system why is it that you're constantly
seeing videos
of people running towards airplanes
um well because they worked with the
west and most of them a lot of them
haven't most of those people that were
running have hadn't worked with the west
and there were just ordinary afghans
some who just wanted to get away i think
one of the
issues in the last couple of days that
i've seen is that a lot of the people
that were in the airport weren't
actually from kabul and the majority
weren't people who had fought and worked
with the west it was just ordinary
afghans who were trying to find an
opportunity
just to get into the airplane
um with no documents no passport or
anything like that so if that was the
case they wouldn't be running um
and i i say this i think the other
problem i'm having is that i come from
afghanistan i have family i have friends
i've traveled there
and yet when i hear people telling me
that that country hasn't progressed or
the mentality hasn't
i dispute that because i feel like we
need to hear from afghans a lot more and
that's the other problem with this is
that
when i was talking about the fact that
afghans are very marginalized group even
in the west
their voices aren't heard
very much i mean you've got caribbean
you've got the black community you've
got south asian like to wet south asia
through indiana pakistanis and so many
others and a lot of them have of course
been here much much longer in britain
afghans are newly arrived you know 15 20
years you're being hurt now
you're right it's great
it took us 20 years yes
we've come to the point we've only been
doing this for three years so you're the
first afghan on the show i believe and
you're very welcome here but look what
i'm talking about is opinion polls right
this isn't he said she said etc and of
course there will be people fleeing war
there'll be people fleeing the taliban
there'll be people who don't want to
live under sharia law as your parents
and your family didn't
but
has what i'm asking is has afghan
society really moved on as much as we'd
like to think
i think
i'm not going to
disagree that afghanistan is a very
complex society and i think i mentioned
a little bit earlier that it's a tribal
society
that lives under tribal practices um
and you know that the woman's role is
not out in the public um
that you know women should have more
than you know five children and you know
very religious very very fundamental um
but it doesn't it it takes time to help
people get out of that mindset
the the other problem is that a lot of
the change were in in cities like
cardboard that's what i was going to ask
and wrote there was a not there wasn't
much intervention and these sort of
big ngos were being funded um by
foreign governments but their work has
was been delivered in the capital cities
and i i find issue with that as well we
weren't actually funding community-led
activities by activists in all across
afghanistan
on a grassroot level this was all done
by save the children or oxfam all these
major organizations that
were working with
community groups and civic society
activists in
cities
with well-established groups already
with people that spoke english um they i
guess they wanted it was easier for them
wasn't it you know to welcome people
that understood the system that they
could communicate with them uh it would
have been a lot harder to go to a raw
place where english wasn't spoken and
trying to deal figure out how to work
around that so
you know they took the easier
option uh and the easiest way out to to
um to change and bring about uh change
in afghanistan so that could have been
one of the cause for the pop the fact
that the poll said that a lot of people
were still quite traditional in their
mindset
but it takes time it really does it's
not an easy
i think people
fail to understand how
backward afghanistan
really was and probably still is in in
like you said in rural areas
there is no country around the world
that has suffered from
40
over 40 years of conflict from 1978
ongoing
that
does not have any system i remember when
i first went even in 2001
there were sewers out in the open you
know people would go to a toilet and it
would come out into the road
um the roads needed fix and the houses
are very old made out of clay and and
mud
so to think that you can change a
country like that
that is tribal that is traditional that
is practically living in the first
century so quickly
is very naive it's something you know
we've we've we've failed to really study
afghanistan properly first of all to
understand its people its culture
where we've started what kind of country
we're actually intervening in and for
example people compare it to iraq but
iraq was a very developed country
yeah and so was syria yeah you know
afghanistan's not the same it's
completely different and the
interventions were different
we were fighting extremism in iraq and
syria
um and fighting daesh but before our
interventions before saddam before assad
these were very very modern westernized
liberal societies
very stable business economy freedom
afghanistan's not the same and i you
know why
try to emphasize to anyone that compares
is please don't compare because
afghanistan is a unique case
it's never been a developed society
and you weren't there to fix a small
problem you were trying you were there
to fix
decades all right let me ask you one
more bad cop question yeah uh before
francis uh jumps in which is with all of
that being the case and
i recognize that from what i know about
that part of the world
i mean you won't like hearing this but
there'll be a lot of people listening to
you going
well i mean we were there for 20 years
we spent two trillion dollars on on
trying to build up this country to make
it a more western more liberal society i
mean how how much more money are british
and american taxpayers how many more
lives how you know
it's it i'm not saying this is an easy
decision but that is how people will be
thinking i mean
another 20 years 40 years sick how long
does it take to take someone in a rural
area of afghanistan
who's maybe never seen electricity let
alone modern western how long does it
take to get that to where you can just
leave it and the taliban aren't gonna
come back and take over because quite a
lot of people are quite happy with what
they're gonna do
oh i understand what you're saying and
the reason why those people ask those
questions is because they think this is
an afghan crisis they don't see this as
a regional or global crisis in on the in
the 21st century we shouldn't even have
a country that lives like that
it's a human issue we need to actually
ask questions why even a country like
that exists first of all
second of all as we've seen from past
history
what happens in afghanistan affects the
west directly it's one of the reasons
why you know we went there in in there
in the first place we were trying to
ensure that our shores and our land is
safe from extremism so we had to go
there to bring stability
it affects us directly here so you're
not going there to fix their problem
you're there to fix them so that it
benefits you and your safety and your
security
and
you know thirdly afghanistan's quite you
know positioned in a really important
geographical area you've got pakistan
and india which is a former british raj
you've got iran which is no friend of
the west you've got central asia which
is under soviet union control you've got
china
so
it's a very important spot if when
you're there
strategically
you can maintain order anywhere
by leaving you've left a vacuum and
already china and russia saying they
they're going to step in and and and
fund the taliban
um you know china's developing that new
silk
belt road across the regions in order to
um to feed their sort of economic
domination ambitions they have so you
know it's not a small matter and i think
when you fail to understand the
political side of this the economic side
of the security
um the diplomatic aspects of afghanistan
afghanistan intervention that's when
you'll understand that you're not there
fixing someone else's problem
you're there to fix your own problem
but in addition to that you're also
trying to give the afghan people some
hope and peace and freedom
um
you know afghans have never kicked out
anyone
by force
it's always been
military intervention and political sort
of games being played in the land
um they are very a vulnerable group
they're very marginalized they're very
you know i'm sure hopefully well you're
not going to be able to travel now or if
you have it in the last 20 years but
let's see what happens but if you do
travel you'll see how simple they live
their lives are very simple
um and i think the only wish i would
have had is
the political elite in afghanistan which
is less than one percent
um are the ones who have caused this
problem as well
the majority of the afghan population
have no hand in what's going on a lot of
them are illiterate have no
understanding of what's happening around
them um it's the political lead who most
of them have come from the west in the
last 20 years actually that's the other
problem is that you have a president and
ministers who've been educated and live
their whole lives in the us and the uk
and europe
step in and say we're going to fix
afghanistan by but never going through
the struggle and the pain of the war so
how can they really be in touch with
what's happening and as you've seen most
of them have actually left
abandoning the country without
any fight
people are very very infuriated with the
president who left even without a notice
of resignation
um managed to take about 136 million
dollars in cash with them though yeah
that's exactly
um i mean it's it's it's traumatic and
it's hard to accept that this is
i think we made huge mistakes right from
the beginning as well by
working with people
who
um
well you know it was easier for the west
to work with people like them because
again there were western
individuals who had grown up and studied
in the west and it's a lot easier to
communicate and deal with them but i
think there's not it wasn't a lot of
energy and hard work and getting actual
people in afghanistan like the actual
afghans get them to a point where there
can be leaders the investment wasn't
made to make new leaders
the investment was on existing people
who you've just bought from the west
to take up these positions
um and who wouldn't last really because
you know you've got to do a passport you
you'll run away any moment when
cadastral strikes don't you think as
well shabnam that the widespread
corruption made the society
fundamentally unsustainable
you can't have society where people
aren't getting paid because every all
the money is getting stolen oh
absolutely i agree um
it's something i've been campaigning
against and i've raised a number of
times that there needs to be a lot more
monitoring
uh of funding that goes in um it
wouldn't have been difficult for for
example the uk to set up a body that
would
ensure that any money that goes in where
it goes who th who it goes to you know
you gave money to to a government and it
wasn't just you know the uk it was
europe and us and the world pledged
billions of pounds
um to afghanistan without surveillance
or or a system or monitoring system of
where it goes and how who it goes to and
and particularly you know people that
were in government
any contracts that came in any of you
there was a lot of opportunity honestly
i think afghanistan had
if we for example went to afghanistan
the last 20 years we would have been
millionaires by now there was so much
opportunity
contracts were being given
offered and
development opportunities
what happened though is a lot of that
was given to close circles so you know
you've got the president he will give it
to his brother or his son or a relative
and they would have this multi-million
contract to develop a factory or
you know buildings and roads um and
would pocket half of that um and
um i mean that's the way it worked and i
think
the fault is both ways both the fact
that we had a very corrupt government um
an irresponsible one and then also the
fact that the international community
gave aid without any bother like where
is it going i think also that's what's
probably infuriated the british public
for instance you're spending all of our
taxpayers money but you're not
monitoring where it's going who it's
going to and a lot of that money didn't
go to the people that should have
had it and
that's the other argument over the fact
that if we if we haven't been able to
develop afghanistan 20 years then what
hope is there for anymore but that money
didn't go to afghans it didn't go to the
everyday people that you that we should
have been working with to change their
mentality to allow their girls to go to
school to change their understanding of
how society runs and to allow them to
become more educated um so if the money
isn't going to the everyday afghan
and it's going in the pockets of the
elite or the people that live in capital
cities how could you expect there to be
any shift in mentality or understanding
um so there were huge failures i'm not
saying it's perfect there was a lot of
mistakes that were made over the last 20
years
in many aspects in terms of aid in terms
of um
understanding the society understanding
the fact that there are different ethnic
groups and ethnicity was another huge
problem in afghanistan you've got the
you've got tajiks you've got uzbeks uh
pastors hazaras
all these ethnic groups also
wanted to be represented and included in
the process um afghanistan's a very
centralized
um system has a um every power
everything was in the centralized
government for example the police would
sorry the president would even recruit
police officers or the teachers i mean
that's how
how much control the president had no
one would be able to make a decision
without him
sounds familiar
and so
people felt neglected people felt
underrepresented they felt that this was
not a system that would that was
inclusive
um
was there a bit of resentment as well
the fact that you know hang on a second
you know none of the people from this
country are actually being truly
represented because you've just flown
someone in from uh from america so
didn't they wasn't there a large part of
them that just saw this as a puppet
regime oh for sure
the majori the majority of the country
did think that they thought you know
you've got a president who actually
made a few mistakes as well one was
actually when he was um it was a prayer
um do an eid i think it was he didn't
know how to pray um sort of the islamic
way of you know going down or there was
an error there um
and then there was also i think he
recited one of the um
islamic verses incorrectly incorrectly
so he made a few mistakes i think
probably why he ran away so quickly was
that he knew that if he fell in the
hands of the taliban
he would have been done
um but yes that was the the major
problem and something i've been dealing
with in that a lot of afghans would say
how can we trust the government that
has not actually come from within the
society
and these are all people you know the
national security advisor was came from
the uk
um
most of the ministers were either from
the us from the uk president ghani was
from the u.s these are very well
educated and and karzai before him and
kaza was from the us as well so really
in the last 20 years there wasn't
actually anyone there weren't very many
people that were from afghanistan and
lived there and raised there um
that were in government
hey constantin do you love trigonometry
of course incredible interviews
hilarious live streams hard hitting
satire plus my handsome jawline whatever
takes away from your hairline but if you
do love trigonometry and you want to
support us there's only one place to do
that and that's on locals yes locals is
a brilliant platform that has been
incredibly supportive to our show and
other problematic creators the great
thing about locals is that it's a
community for people who love
trigonometry that's right it's a place
for you to hang out with like-minded
people share thoughts memes and discuss
the show you can enjoy it for free but
it also gives you the option of
supporting us for as little as seven
dollars a month and if you want to give
more you can we have incredible rewards
for our higher tier supporters as well
we've got everything from mugs monthly
group calls and one-on-two chats with me
and kcat get in join our community by
hitting the link in the description and
the pin comment below see you there guys
i gotta be honest with you
as much empathy as i feel for the people
of afghanistan of course i do you're not
you're not convincing me that the us and
the uk should stay it just sounds like
such a nightmare and how are you gonna
how are you gonna distribute funds
without an elite and how are you do you
see what i'm saying it just sounds like
such a massive mess
it was a mess because we didn't do it
the right way the first time
i think
staying
listening understanding
what afghanistan is what kind of nation
it is listening to the very people that
we've ignored for so long
it would have been a shift and a change
and i'm not convincing you because
you're still looking at it in terms of
the nation-building part of it
we need to we need
i understand there were failures when it
comes to the country itself
but when it comes to british foreign
policy
i agree with you on the security aspect
security economics absolutely diplomatic
around yeah yeah i agree but by
staying
in afghanistan despite its failures
you were giving back
whilst gaining a lot more yeah i i get
that so
yes it's it takes a lot of effort it's
difficult and my
suggestions and recommendations have
always been
let's work with the communities that
have been mod sort of isolated for so
long the people that you do not
and have not consulted with even in the
last three years of the peace process
no one's actually
none of the um the negotiations whether
it was in doha russia and iran these see
the you know high level
meetings they were all with the top
political lead you know karzai and his
group and the people in government i we
there was no reps from the youth there
was no
representatives from the young women
the new generation the different ethnic
groups so
so many failures and i think it came out
of either comfort or the fact that
you've worked with one group so for so
long you just you rely on them to do
everything right
it takes a lot more effort and time and
management to to train
individuals who
aren't used to western ways of working i
guess or can't speak english very well
or just aren't familiar
with
how to
negotiate how to speak how to be
politically educated so it i know it
takes a lot more time and effort but i
think we took the easier way out by
working with a group that just was
familiar for us
was a group that we've
either trained or worked with in the
west and have formed existing
relationship with so let me ask you
about another what you might describe as
a simple way not necessarily easy way
out but the one that that i'm starting
to see in the british media
being taken we saw only a couple of days
ago i retweeted this clip of
i think he's the chief of the general
staff so he's the head of the british
army on sky news he's being interviewed
and i think it's k burley asks him about
uh the taliban you know how do we deal
with this enemy and he says oh we
mustn't call them the enemy
because we wouldn't want to that they
promised to have an inclusive
approach to yeah yeah yeah yeah it seems
to me
like the west is
considering taking
what you will certainly and i consider a
very cynical approach which is saying
look the taliban have taken over right
this is who who's going to be there and
in terms of our geostrategic interest
they're the people we have to deal with
now like and they're going to do what
they're going to do and it's horrible
and we're going to put hashtags on
instagram and whatever but the reality
is we're going to deal with these people
we're going to
bribe them or threaten them or do
whatever we need to do to to get them
not to harbor terrorists and apart from
that
what are you going to do is that do you
think what's going to happen here it's
something i don't want to happen
but i fear
and you're right um
the fact that we
we withdrew from afghanistan so quickly
we took us lead here um
by claiming this is the u.s led
intervention it had nothing to do with
us and
um
you know they made the call we just had
to follow and we couldn't do this on our
own i you know i get that but
to where does global britain come into
this so whether is this influential
humanitarian leading humanitarian actor
that we are around the world come into
this and the fact that
we we have a history uh a proud history
of doing things like this on our own why
suddenly we've become so reliant on the
us first of all
second of all
what's difficult for me i think as
someone from afghanistan is accepting
that we withdrawn militarily but if
you're going to withdraw politically and
diplomatically in human in terms of
humanitarian ways well i think
that's
that's shameful
to only think of your political interest
in something like this and not the human
side of this
um
is catastrophic you know
we
i don't want the taliban to be first of
all seen as a legitimate government
but if even if it is
i expect that once that you've done this
you this catastrophe has always happened
already happened
but the the the least that i would
expect is that you would monitor what's
happening you will keep an eye out
you will pressure them to not go back
into their old ways um and you will hold
them to account how how do you pressure
the taliban not to go into their own
ways how do you do that well you i mean
you work you develop a relationship with
them of course that's important you've
got to engage with them um
but by ensuring that you know there are
repercussions for what if if they do go
back there are do you have to threaten
them that you're going to bomb them
well i was going to say back to the
stones i think that's what the u.s has
said that it would do um that if you if
you do
allow the country to become a safe haven
for terrorism again right we will do
that um
but
it's sad because the country just goes
through cycle after cycle of war it's
just never ending i feel for the people
because
it's not their call it's not you know
it's not something
um
and sometimes we blame afghans and say
you know well this is your country and
you haven't been able to fix it but it
really isn't up to them it's never been
up to the african people
i know i'm coming across very cold and
heartless yeah it's because i am but
but and i'm russian but but actually i'm
asking you these questions because i
know this is what people are thinking at
home right
because that's what people are thinking
and uh i think
we're seeing certainly the political
leaders going down the path i've gone
well look the taliban have taken over
like you said we've got to engage with
them and if they start allowing
terrorists
coming into camps and whatever will bomb
you but apart from that i just think
we've kind of lost any levers of
influence haven't we at this point as
the west
we have by
allowing them to step in unconditionally
i think the mistakes were made
when the peace process started um
they asked for their prisoners to be
released before they even started
conversations we agreed without
negotiation and
imagine allowing a group of 5 000
prisoners to be released who were
extremist terrorists murderers
um to release from prison during the
negotiations um because they said well
we're not going to sit around the table
and talk to you until you do that
um
that was an error
how could you give in to something like
that so quickly totally um
second of all
the u.s signs an agreement and says
we're going to leave but set snow
conditions and
and
and
there's no talk about compromise no talk
about changing ideology no talk about
accepting this this new afghanistan
you just said as long as you don't touch
you know us troops
you can do what you want um
it's shameful i think the the the
my anger is more towards the us than
anything else
um they've already shaped what what kind
of country they want to be moving
forward i don't think anyone's ever
going to trust them to be a friend or an
ally again
um and i think
trump's isolationism um
theory and the way he that he wanted
america to be is what biden is
delivering on i think
what was interesting was when trump was
in power and he started this whole thing
everyone thought well he's an evil man
he's a
horrible individual and he he started
this and he doesn't care
and everyone had so much hope that when
biden comes in he's going to reverse
this decision
he will put conditions on this peace
process he will do something or he will
he will just extend the withdrawal date
to make sure there's a meaningful
discussion and actually he made it a
thousand times worse and
every speech i hear from him about
afghanistan is so uncompassionate so
there's no understanding there's no care
for what happens to the people of
afghanistan uh and i think that's what
makes this even worse it's infuriating
to listen to someone who just doesn't
give any he doesn't care um
and and
yeah i think america has already
shown us what kind of country it's going
to be and it's not going to be one
that's a friend ever again i think to
anyone no one's going to trust the u.s
again who's going to trust that the u.s
will endure and persevere and stick it
out when when it's hard
anywhere else in the world and i think
this is where britain can step in this
is where
when we talk about global britain when
we talk about this new identity that we
have
outside of the eu we want to be more
global we want to work with other
countries outside of europe
along comes with that a lot of
responsibility um
and i think potentially this will be an
era for the for the uk to show a lot
more independence a lot more leadership
that doesn't rely on the us
and shabnam what it was the future now
going to hold for afghanistan
i think from
[Music]
i mean in terms of
on the ground
it's going to be a very bleak future
um it's going to be a very difficult one
i know that for sure
and the taliban
rule this is not going to be
um an easy um
society um i mean we've we saw the press
conference from the taliban it was
yesterday or the day before that
we know them saying that
we've changed we're going to allow women
and girls to study and to work and that
we allow free press
but when it comes to what they've
actually been doing in action um it's
completely different um
we've i've heard you know stories of
women uh being told they would they
won't be working and as presenters from
monday um you know women and girls have
been told to go back home and not go to
school
um and you know every argument they make
is you know if you ask them if we'll
have you the people who have their
rights they say well under sure
you will so what is actually that what
does that mean because actually
the the last 20 years the government of
afghanistan actually had an islamic
constitution it was an islamic
government so what what why is taliban
islamic
practices so different what makes it
different that's still unclear we still
don't know what what's the difference
but in terms of afghanistan
moving forward it's going to be a very
very very difficult next few years if
not next decade
um i do foresee that britain will step
in i think potentially it will form a
new coalition
um it's something that i'm hearing um
from from mps and from people who you
know tobias elwood and ben wallace and a
few others are looking at potentially
seeing how the uk can step in without
the us when the time comes and when it's
needed
um and that is what i'd like to see i
think
we there will be a time for sure that we
will need to step in um afghanistan
historically
has never been a country where it's been
on its own for for too long it's um you
know it hasn't been able to survive on
its own and it's one of the most
dependent countries on foreign aid
in the world it doesn't it can't survive
the institution and the infrastructure
isn't there
for it to have its own economy to feed
its people to have a society and a
system it needs a foreign intervention
to survive and unfortunately you know
that's not something i want i'm sure
that's not what the people of
afghanistan want and i'm sure most of
the people of afghanistan didn't want
nato and the west to be stationed there
forever
um but when you do go
and you spend 20 years
why would you wash that down the drain
and then potentially start again from
scratch in the next 10 years or less
um it's just the reality of the country
it's the way it's
always been
and what do you think china and russia's
role will be in this new afghanistan
it's not going to be a good one that's
for sure um
it's you know china
is
is looking at
its own economic domination uh in the
region so we'll be funding the taliban
we'll be spending money in afghanistan
as long as potentially they agree not to
uh meddle in their plans um you always
ask so much [ __ ] depressing questions
mate
and russia the same i guess russians
mention has never been a positive one
anywhere in the world
um so
what about venezuela how are they doing
no it's okay um and
you know you've got iran on the other
side who is so anti-west
um that it will do anything to make sure
that we don't go back in there um
and then you've got a proxy war with
pakistan who you know support clearly
have shown support to the taliban so
afghanistan's very you know stuck in the
middle unfortunately it's it's got
neighbors that don't really have its
best inter interest at heart and even in
the last couple of days a week um
you know let alone the west opening its
borders its neighbors haven't opened its
borders
no one's allowing anyone to get out to
some central asian countries iran or
anywhere else i think india has just
started to see if it can issue visas but
what can you expect from anyone else
when your own neighbors don't really
want to let you through so yeah it's
it's going to be a difficult one well
look you bring up an important issue and
i wish we had more time but we'll finish
talking about the refugee situation and
obviously your family having come to the
uk and all of you doing very well you're
making a huge contribution it's such a
pleasure to have you on the show
um i i know you'll feel strongly about
it personally but there's also a bigger
conversation to be had about it as well
so let's let's try and have that because
you know my view is anyone who's who's
worked with british or american forces
deserves to be given the opportunity to
be safe from what will certainly be
reprisals and they're going to be
murdered
but
i've always as a as a first-generation
immigrant like you i've always felt that
it is the job of the british government
to ensure that the immigration system is
fair and is seen to be fair including by
the people of britain yeah because when
things like this happen when there's a
genuine refugees and there will be you
know a few tens of thousands it's not a
huge number by the standards of a
country but if you've had this kind of
drip drip drip effect over the last 15
20 years where people feel like it
hasn't quite been calibrated correctly i
mean brexit which i know you were a big
fan of partly was driven by the desire
to control the immigration system do you
fear now that some of the people who
i think you but you and i both agree
should be given the opportunity to come
and to be safe and to be rewarded for
for risking their lives essentially to
work with british and american forces
are probably not going to be given that
opportunity because of the system that
we've had or do you think we will look
after the people that we should look
after
i think in terms of immigration i
completely agree with you we've got to
make sure that genuine asylum seekers
who are fleeing war and conflict are
given priority unfortunately though
um being part of the european union has
meant that over the years we've accepted
people that were here as economic
migrants and simply wanted a job uh or
all to study um
and you know sources
then applied for asylum um and it did
anger a lot of british nationals in
terms of how can everyone coming here
you know and it does damage the british
infrastructure and its economy in a
society the uk is such a small island
it's it's tiny in comparison to canada
or the us or so many russia
or russia or so many of the european
countries germany france um that we
expect the uk to take everything now i
agree with that you know it's not fair
um we have to also look after our own a
surgeon in
immigration does mean that our health
system takes the brunt um
people then are in waiting lists for the
nhs and schools and housing so i i
completely understand that i'm for that
uh but i think when it comes to a crisis
like this
you've got to step in and take and and
show responsibility particularly when
the burden is on you because of the
actions that you you took and the
decision you took and you know in
britain's case
you left and you withdraw afghanistan
you weren't kicked out you weren't
forced out you took that decision
independently and as a result of that
the country's in crisis now so i think
it's important for us to
make sure that we have you know we take
our moral obligation um is more
important than anything else in in a
situation like this so i would like to
see the uk step up first of all support
those who served with the british
government with the army
and supported its mission in afghanistan
but also those i think the eligibility
in terms of resettlement is a bit vague
at the moment and it's not the agreement
isn't as expanded as it should be
because the young generation of afghans
who worked as journalists who worked as
teachers as activists as worked in ngos
those people who were very outspoken
very active in the social sort of in the
public space
those people will be
particularly i mean their lives will be
under threat because
we we went in there and supported them
we we gave them the morale we gave them
the funding the the the hope that this
is the afghanistan we've shaped for you
um and then you take that away
these people will be attacked because
they developed under your supervision so
even though they didn't actually
directly work with you
they became who they are through your
support so i think there's also that
responsibility to make sure that those
people that
uh are you know
become educated and and
flourished in this afghanistan um
don't end up being killed because not
only will we have to start from scratch
in the next couple of years if we do go
back
but we'll also have to retrain and
re-educate everyone again because the
the generation that we supported so much
have all been lost and killed um so i
think generally speaking there is a huge
moral obligation now to resettle and
support those that uh that need us
shamnam thank you so much for coming on
the show we really do appreciate it
we've got a few questions for our locals
but before we do that we always end the
interview with our final question which
is what's the one thing we're not
talking about but we really should be
i think for me it's
making sure that we hear from the people
of afghanistan
not only in inside but outside i think
too too much sacrifice too much time has
been spent in the country and so i mean
afghans are the second ranked refugees
now uh population around the world that
they're there and they will be
increasing now because of this
um we've got to make sure that
when it comes to the topic on
afghanistan
that we first and foremost hear from
them you know sometimes these
conversations happen we hear from
academics we hear from politicians we
hear from anyone and everyone that isn't
from afghanistan um from spaces that
i've sort of been in and yes
you've said to me that i'm here today
and i you know you've invited me and i'm
an afghan voice but one person isn't
enough you need a lot more you need a
huge
focus on on the afghan crisis not only
inside but outside because this issue
isn't going away anytime soon and in
order to find a better approach if we do
look at afghanistan again any time in
the future you've got to understand its
people it's culture
you know who they are where they come
from what they believe in and that's the
only way to to make sure that we don't
make the same mistakes we made in the
last 20 years
thanks for coming on champion uh where
can people find you and your work online
follow your commentary etc um they can
follow me on twitter um
most of my work is on there but um yeah
and just follow me online all right
fantastic well thanks for coming on and
thank you all for watching at home and
listening at home we will see you very
soon with another brilliant episode and
of course if you're on locals we'll ask
some bonus questions of shamnam in a
second take care and see you soon
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below